hi I'm Evan Carmichael walk another
edition of ask Evan in today to do I'm
going to answer question from one of my
readers Trina who was a single mom she
wants to run the business she's looking
for a mentor to help her her main vision
behind it is because she wants to build
a better life for herself and for her
daughter who's just growing up and I
think that's something a lot of people
can relate to they want to build a
better lives for themselves and for
their family in terms of finding a
mentor I think the first thing you need
to do is identify what you need help
with so it wasn't clearing the email
that you sent exactly what you need help
with and when you're going and looking
for a mentor you want to be really
specific as to where you need help so
you know people that you talk to are
going to be able to give you advice or
refer you to people depending on what
you asked so it's just saying you
looking for mentor doesn't necessarily
help but if you say I need somebody to
help me with my website idea or
marketing or grow my business or raising
capital whatever it is then you start
getting people thinking about how they
can potentially help you either
themselves or pass name on to you to
help you out I've seen a lot of times a
lot of entrepreneurs that I meet with
here in Toronto will come and ask me for
help and I try to help as much as
possible when somebody has a really
clear goal of what they want to
accomplish it's easier for me to help
them it's easier for me to mentor them
or to give them connections to people or
think and help them if they're I'm very
vague then it's harder for me to help
and I have to kind of drill down and try
to figure out what it is that they need
help with and so people may spend that
time with you but a lot of people won't
so you want to try to get as clear as
possible as to what you need help with
so that when you are talking to people
it's easier for them to give you
contacts and and give you advice to help
you out the other part of that is so
that's great you're out there you're
talking people you really clear and you
will get people who can help you the
second part is you don't have to get
mentored by people who you actually know
and i found that i've got a lot of
advice and I can sit a lot of people to
be my mentors and people I look up to
who have never actually met and I
learned
about them through books I read and
stories online and profiles that we even
do in a my own website and I call it
modern masters where you're looking at
famous entrepreneurs who look up to and
you get their advice by listening to how
they started their business and I find a
lot of value in that hopefully you know
you guys do as well and that's why we do
the regular videos on it but you know
what I'm looking for marketing device
there's people who I know who I can talk
to about marketing but I also look at
guys like Richard Branson and how did
they market their business and guys like
Donald Trump and how do they promote
themselves there's lessons you can learn
success leaves clues I look into these
famous entrepreneurs who look up to and
a tent it helps to look at people who
are inspiring to you and whose story you
really appreciate anything you can
resonate well with and you can have them
as your informal Board of Advisors you
know how would I market like Richard
Branson as an example and they can help
you grow your business as well even
though you've never actually met them so
both sides of the corn again it's still
going to come down to really being clear
of their what you need help with asking
people exactly for that help and then
also looking to other resources beyond
your network looking up the famous
entrepreneur is the same lessons you can
learn from their success so hopefully
that helps you start that business and
grow it and you can build that better
life for for you and your daughter good
luck if you have other questions let me
know for those watching if you liked the
video please leave a thumbs up below I
always like seeing those come in so
thank you and if you have questions feel
free to leave a comment below we have
other thoughts as well to add to this
video feel free to leave it in the
comment underneath and we'll see you on
the next episode
you
you